jonas für mich doch mal hier durch deine
also hier haben wir einen neuen lüfter
sind die ganze dann blasen
es ist fantastisch genauso was sie tun
sagt so jetzt kann man hier hintergarten
vögel sind
mit ihm freuen und herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge g t au
auf 95 millionen das lka mit hut und wo
befinden wir uns gerade jonas es geht
hier in der villa jamm an in der hitler
playboy hatte pastor richtig schön rein
mitternacht jetzt hier mache niemand
einen besuch
aber ich fühle mich jetzt immer ein
bisschen rum wie meine tolle wildungen
ich habe mir extra ihn vom rest her
angepasst das ist gut kann man hier mit
rum hier hinten vorsichtig fahren auch
schon wieder draußen
ja du ich habe ein schlüssel ist
natürlich die dürfe mich offen also auch
ein schlüssel für die budget zusammen
jetzt erwarte ich zeig dir das hier ist
die grünfläche hier geht's auf jeden
fall nicht lange aber spielte villa hat
natürlich noch viel mehr zu bieten
man kann natürlich hier lang fahren so
hier kann man mit
dann kann man hier die kleinen grill
hoch her geht dann moment
die ich hier gebaut haben
wenn du premium driving skills haben die
habe ich glücklich bin ich schon wieder
am export ja bei mir läuft auch nicht
das ist so gern wie meine gerade einfach
nicht gewusst wie mario kart in scheiße
wie so oft den falschen weg gefahren und
zwar hätten wir eigentlich ganz anders
rum wo bist du denn jonas erwarte ich
mache gerade eine kleine abstecher auf
den tenniscourt
ich habe meine bank gemacht also ein
bisschen wie es laufen und man ferdinand
ist ihr wieder eine bank bitte um die
schon kaputt ist jetzt läuft der mich
gerade eine heftige party deswegen ist
ja auch da die geile beleuchtung mit der
medien und der der miley und miley
stewart miley ja die die zwerg das ist
aber drin dadurch extra form vorgezogen
aber wir können mal eben hier
runterladen wenn wir das denn können so
wohnen und hier sehen wir dann auch
schon meine google google das war
richtig glück ja da ist ein offroad
anrufen
ich bin mein haar hat sie überlebt ich
will einsteigen
damit kommt die goulagou i ja ich bin
hammam stimmen dann kann wieder deine
anmacht tricks anwenden
ich habe gelernt ich hab das alles
gebaut dass man die ohren radio
übrigens jonas hat sich extra für uns
heute die schale geschmissen er kölner
geht es zur wochenmitte wir werden daher
bittet revier krake war hier aber was
ich weiß nicht was meine krankheit
endlich gas geben konnte gibt dir das
hier die star gala wie macht man das
sportblatt as naja egal komme und hier
nämlich zum drink haben ja klar wenn
dabei ja oh warte ich muss drin stehen
es ist irgendwie so einsam hier ist ja
was du noch etwas mit wodka whisky würde
kommt ihr da sonst noch was erwartet
euch zu den champagner die zu den
champagner nicht kaputt
ja der hat passiert jedoch kaputt ist es
geht auch kaputt jetzt komm papa haben
die kröten das war die revanche für die
ganzen andere sache dass irgendwo du
mich gedreht sie waren doch selbst kommt
da der neuigkeit hat nun tut mich mal
getötet so schiebt jetzt mein neid
stecken so erst mal wo ich muss schon
damit ich meinen kunden an ihr alter das
ist das schwierigste ist die örtliche
wieder rauszukommen dieser verkappten
villacher jetzt heftig alles draußen was
du wenn man nicht ganz so kleine
städtchen fest
wenn man sich nicht ganz so blöd
anstellt ist das relativ einfach 500
dollar kostet nur in einigkeit bilder
egal mein auto kostet 1000 wenn ich das
bei mmos mitchell adam meint warum sonst
sind also unsere heutige folge wird
daraus bestehen dass wir uns ein paar
geile will dann gucken da ein bisschen
abdecken
zu mtv cribs mäßig geht zeigen können
wie ein mini häuser die bullen fahren
direkt an mir vorbei hier komme ich mal
ab eur ich bin die links werden mücken
nicht historisch text fertig habt wieder
ich habe wohl damit du kannst dich über
ein stück vorfahren du kommst du hast
gesagt du hast gesagt ich kann nicht
rein macht dass meine einstellung will
kann ich ja nicht dass die grünen weil
ich probiert ich mache einfach schnell
bergtheim und in der zeit stellen ein
damit die bullen sind auf eine mine
weil er hier beraten das stand du das
nicht hast du interesse hast du denn
heute nicht bewegen weil ich mal die
bullen schießen auf mich jetzt kommt ja
unglaublich aber es sieht auch schon
wieder auf diese geile uni so eine [ __ ]
in die usa
hier würde ich lieber wieder zurück in
unsere spiele aber das ist aus game
check wird jeden verrücken hinter vettel
was kann man eigentlich im kino machen
drin sitzt nämlich dann einfach ein kino
gehen aber das erstmal das erste mal
hier erstmal gucken sie verstehen ihren
mädchen soll was ich hier so alles noch
vor finden wir hier auch der schöne
peters hier offen geht nicht aufgefallen
ich glaube es gibt noch ein paar andere
geile falls ich war schon in zweien war
ich noch drin
also was heißt in dem tempo das verbot
ich hoffe diese setzen
er hat uns gesehen aber egal ich mit
meinen fast ums leben
das geht relativ schnitt so
da kann man keine wahl mehr
schwul kräfte die ersten rampen nee das
ist eine rampe was das von anderen seite
ja weil der wahl wie sie sind die büsche
so stein
weder als los ja geil wenn wir die
bullen los sind direkt wieder neue bonus
ja wir wollen auch ihren gesamte
ausprobieren ja und dann darum musst du
dich umbringen ständig ändern wenn sie
auch tun mir aufzurichten und hier
kannst du auch schön 100 jahren genau
hier einfach geradeaus dann wird sich
genau da vorgefertigte rampe der
borussia
das richtig oder wollen sie mir weg in
ein am ufer so geil ein bisschen hier
noch ein dass jetzt die villa hier an
seit für die uns so jonas für mich doch
mal hier durch
also hier haben wir einen neuen lüfter
sind die ganze dann blasen ist fand dass
ich genauso was sie tun sagt so jetzt
kann man hier wintergarten vögel in der
menge sind den asiatischen gleichzeitig
vögel
nein ich mich schauen was man hier wie
sie sind die alle lehren aber erst noch
einarbeiten aber vielleicht noch ein
bisschen luft der 94
da halte ich hier kommen noch palmenhain
einige sind schon prime noch mehr feiern
community auf zu helden sind zusätzlich
im pool whirlpool für die splash pitches
ach ja und das ist mein gärtner pablo
angegriffen hat eigentlich ist meine
bitte aber rein können wir glaube ich
eine chance gehabt einen schlüssel
wieder vergessen zu bleiben
so kann nach vorne und die schöne
hauswand
hier nochmal gebläse und stromkasten
da ist er wieder richtig investieren die
schöne fassade zeigt zu was kommen
geweckt geweckt mit goulagou oder sogar
weise ich habe keinen einzigen
ordentlichen luft gesehen ich will mir
unser das war's auch schon jetzt können
wir fahren ja jetzt sag ich dir doch
meinem eine zweite villa auf jeden fall
noch mal kurz raus
danke dafür
meine frau und also bei mir ist immer
gute stimmung weil man in der mülltonne
nein also kann man ja zum kind dort
punkten muss ag in die backe löschen
nein ich mich um nein ein halb tobias
last das ist bei mir liegen die schon
weiter offen boden ja bei mir jetzt auch
und ich auf mit ihm kann man kann man
dann rocken
nochmal meine zeit wie komme ich erst
mit 396 com jetzt du eine rolle
das hier ist nämlich meine villa da will
man muss immer damit das ist ein code
wenn man da rein will muss man erst mal
das auto steigen
treten die wirklich und da muss man sich
ducken und dann muss man wieder lassen
und war anders geht nicht und jetzt
jetzt jetzt ganz mitkommen ist das mit
kommissar ich das hier mal
also bei meiner villa hier kann man hier
rum gehen und dann habe ich hab nicht
noch sagen ich habe auch so ein pablo
er ist der pressesprecher spuren passten
jetzt schon gute edv der pole servus
irgendwann tut ist eigentlich schlecht
aber das war der der den
nichtschwimmerbereich da waren die
treppen ja ich habe extra trend im markt
für meine ganzen 1000 kinder gesprochen
man kann ja auch einfach wieder raus
dann habe ich hier ein mega stylischen
santana ich hab da das gespann dann von
einem pablo noch genommen
jedenfalls richtig aber nicht so hier
sieht man meinen mega meisten sandberg
von dem ich immer schön rüber zu den
nachbarn gucke os sind selbst verdient
kommt aber in wirklichkeit sind das
alles 500 euro scheine die ich klein
geschnitten habe alles klar
youtube wie du weißt ja hier sehen wir
meinen alten gärtner
das war mein gerne wenn man jetzt noch
nicht vorbei oder ich dachte kommt man
noch anders jetzt erstmal ein toller
ball com den kann man auch wenn man will
dann halt auch zerstören so ein bisschen
dann warte ich kann theoretisch
böblingen toll aber auch dann balkon
gestoßen und die cops kommen sollen die
kacke ja hier ist ein festzelt mir
scheiße denn wenn die partys mit 500
leuten machen das fing an zu regnen der
quetsche uns einfach runter mit keiner
nass passen alle hunde ja alle wenn man
dann dreifach vierfach übereinander legt
dann passt das schon
das will ich sagen das war heute das
waren dann erstmal so unsere beiden
häusern ja es war auf jeden fall
spannend vielen zuschauer und das war
mtv cribs 12 gekürzt und was man wird
dann stehen wir ja du ich hab ne gute
kommt mit ihr ich hab grad wieder diesem
geld vor dem team mut gemacht
zwei sekunden 218
schlaggleich mit einer flasche jetzt
haben wir wieder den notarzt der nur
noch den kopf ist tot
im 3 sterne ja was wir in die kopfstimme
aber wir kommen wir versuchen jetzt fünf
sterne